messieurs
bonsoir fois savez celle internet qui
s'appelle signature view nous vous
reçoit dans le domaine d'une interview
concernant la concentration des médias
le pouvoir et tout un tas de sujets nous
avons en direct de jean pierre canet
ancien rédacteur en chef d' envoyé
spécial bonsoir gros rebond soir david
koubbi qui est notre avocat docteur
en droit à votre docteur en droit de
l'information c'est ça en dehors de la
presse qu' en droit de la presse mme
ainsi comment
ça va
comment ça va la france
la concentration des pouvoirs
médiatiques ans va moins bien moins bien
qui commence alors
redit bas c'est vrai que ça va moins
bien enfin c'est paradoxal j'aime danser
dans une très longue conférence nom en
gros la concentration des médias en
france elle est très forte effectivement
vous avons depuis quelques années on a
beaucoup de tycoon qui prennent le
pouvoir des médias classiques et puis
qui existent aussi sur internet alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya un peu
plus d'argent pour travailler je pense
que je prends un exemple par exemple le
journal le monde a beaucoup renouvelé
son travail a notamment une cellule
enquête qui est très forte et d'ailleurs
en france l'investigation que c'est de
ça dont on va parler qui est quand même
le sujet sensible dans la concentration
des médias se porte plutôt bien on a
quelques îlots comme ça qui travaille
bien on a d'abord les pure players comme
mediapart qui sont maintenant des
rédactions qui sont vraiment intégré au
paysage français qui font un travail
formidable et puis moi ces dernières
années avec cash investigations envoyé
spécial ou complément d enquête non
camarade d'à côté ou pièces à conviction
sur france 3 on a bien vu qu'il ya le
[grognement] service public nous
permettait de faire de l' enquête est
d'enfer avec une très grande liberté et
du temps pour travailler donc
l'investigation se porte bien et en même
temps les mouvements de concentration
des médias et là on le voit
particulièrement avec par exemple la
prise de canal+ par vincent bolloré mais
aussi d'autres journaux
fait peser à terme un risque sur la
liberté d'informer pourquoi pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'un certain
nombre de ces industriels ou de ces
financiers qui prennent le pouvoir des
médias ont des intérêts ailleurs que
dans le divertissement la communication
ou le journalisme est donc le cas
d'école je suis pas obsédé mais c'est le
bouquin qu'on s'en rend ce moment sur
vincent bolloré et qui s'appelle vincent
tout puissant on raconte la prise de
canal+ du groupe canal+ par par vincent
bolloré quand
vous avez quand ces industriels ou ses
financiers ont des intérêts autres que
ce que je viens de citer c'est à dire du
contenu médiatique souvent lorsqu'il
s'agit d'informations leur
intérêt rentre en contradiction avec les
intérêts qu l'intérêt du droit à
l'information de la liberté d'informer
très simplement en posant la question
aujourd'hui ce qu'il est possible quand
on est journaliste à ses news d'enquêter
sur l'huile de palme sachant que vincent
bolloré est dans cette activité là où
sur les ports en afrique pour l'instant
force est de constater que dans ce
groupe là en particulier ça n'est plus
possible
voilà donc c'est en ça qu'on est dans
une situation paradoxale où
l'investigation se porte bien et en même
temps de gros danger pèsent sur elle je
vous rendez preuve que c'est plus
possible je alors à canal+ ah oui il ya
énormément de preuves c'est la case
baissé en fait d'abord il y a qu'à lire
le bouquin de je suis un peu de promo
mais non il ya énormément d'exemple
liban d'abord ça a commencé avec
malheureusement avec nous c'est à dire
mon kotor nicolas veskovac chi et moi
même et puis geoffrey livolsi qu'était
le l'autre auteur d'un documentaire qui
s'appelait sur le crédit mutuel sur donc
poche la banque pasche il s'agissait
d'évasion fiscale présumé il s'agissait
également de blanchiment d'argent il se
trouve que quand on a enquêté sur ce
sujet que nous devions produire au sein
de la gent ce cas m pour canal+ pour
spécial investigation et bien nous avons
été arrêtés dans notre élan puisque en
fait et ça on ne le savait pas le crédit
mutuel était en train de travailler avec
vincent bolloré pour sa montée au
capital de vivendi et donc notre sujet a
été empêchée d'être diffusé sur canal
plus et ça a été le début d'une longue
liste de sujet qui ont été freinés qui
ont été retirés
de la liste jusqu'à la suppression de
spécial investigation et puis ensuite la
deuxième phase a été on a eu un exemple
dernièrement avec un reportage
problématique est étudié par le sait ça
aujourd'hui en fait un reportage qui est
probablement une publicité pour le togo
un pays où vincent bolloré des activités
importantes un sujet qui est venu en
contres d'un autre reportage qui avait
été diffusée sur canal+ par l'effet
papillon sur les manifestations au togo
contre le président gnassingbé en
octobre ce
sujet n'a pas plu au président
gnassingbé vincent bolloré l'a fait
retirer du replay de canal+ et a eu
beaucoup d'histoires on sait que c'est
lui qui le fait retirer alors c'est vrai
qu'on sait pas si c'est lui stricto
sensu qu'a dit on arrête ça les éléments
dont nous disposons c'est à dire le
timing le sujet est diffusée en france
en octobre deux jours après il est
supprimée du replay sachant que vincent
bolloré quelqu'un comme nous l'indiquons
de tout puissant dans son groupe il est
probable qu'il ait donné des ordres à la
direction de canal+ directement ou
indirectement pour retirer sujet on
constate mais pas certain je suis pas
dans son bureau donc je ne sais pas ce
qui est certain c'est que le sujet a
bien été retiré et que plusieurs
péripéties à cette aventure là et que
donc là en décembre le 22 décembre
dernier un sujet réparateur entre
guillemets a été diffusée sur l'antenne
de canal+ à 7 heures du matin peu en
catimini à la gloire du togo de faure
gnassingbé
le csa s'est penché sur la question il
est en train de se penser pencher sur la
question pardon et doit savoir si oui ou
non il s'agit d'un reportage positif
comme l'a qualifié la direction qui n
est plus aussi il s'agit d'une espèce de
publicité déguisée à la gloire du
président pour rétablir
pour calmer un peu le président
gnassingbé qui avait été fort en colère
de la diffusion de ce sujet de l'étape
est en contradiction totale avec la
charte de munich oui alors c'est vrai
que je parle sous le contrôle de
l'avocat mais on a on a dans le
journalisme et réguler un petit peu
comme les médecins avec le serment
d'hippocrate on a nous quelques charte
on a évidemment une loi en france qui
était en revue plusieurs fois sur
liberté d'informer comme dans toutes les
démocraties mais on a une charte qui
régit notre profession qui est qui donne
un petit peu la déroute la déontologie
du journalisme et qui est une charte qui
a été écrite en 1971 et la charte de
munich beaucoup de pays européens
notamment l'ont signé et c'est vrai que
cette charte je crois pas qu'aujourd'hui
à ces news ou dans le groupe canal+ on
pourrait l'assumer entièrement
d'ailleurs
une charte a été réécrite dernièrement
par par les journalistes enfin en tout
cas par la rédaction de ces news dont
plusieurs points entre en contradiction
avec cette charte je prends un exemple
il
est autorisé dans cette charte écrite au
sein de ces news qu'un journaliste
puisse faire ce qu'on appelle des
ménages c'est ce que c'est des ménages
c'est quand un journaliste lui arrondir
ses fins de mois et va par exemple animé
une conférence payer donc par telle ou
telle entreprise ou telle ou telle
organisation
et ça dans notre déontologie c'est
interdit pourquoi parce que évidemment
on rentre immédiatement aux conflits
sion si on est payé par une banque pour
les animer une conférence sur le marché
financier on peut difficilement ensuite
avoir l'indépendance critères
intellectuelle à la crédibilité pour
traiter ces sujets bon bah ça dans la
charte nouvelle charte de canal+ par
exemple c'est autorisé il suffit juste
de signaler sa la direction bon je
regarde on va donner à prendre tout de
suite dit oui mais avant tu pris la
parole j'ai une question à se poser est
ce que nous changions tube chaîne
internet
qui diffusion sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'on prend des risques à
recevoir ce type de journalistes un peu
tête brûlée de l'information ce que nous
tous sur je récuse ce terme récuse le
remplacer par quoi part
j'aurais mis en service en août en temps
il ya 2 il ya deux procès que je récuse
la tête brûlée et le procès au gauchisme
nous sommes si nous faisons bien notre
travail et il est parfois difficile un
contre pouvoir c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre le procès rango schisme
commence à me fatiguer un peu pourquoi
est ce qui fait la richesse du diamant
mais bien sûr mais de toute façon c'est
le jeu du débat on est là pour répondre
aux questions n'est pas au dessus des
questions peut pas demander aux autres
de répondait pas répondre à nouveau
question le procès en gauchisme et il
est très facile et très pratique
pourquoi on nous le fait parce que
effectivement on enquête alors via cash
investigations par exemple ou mediapart
sur d'autres sujets on enquête sur les
grandes entreprises mais pourquoi on
enquête sur des ententes sur les grandes
entreprises pardon parce que le pouvoir
aujourd'hui appartient essentiellement
aux grandes entreprises donc fatalement
assez naturellement nous allons d'abord
enquêter sur ce principal pouvoir si
nous étions sous un régime plus
socialistes communistes ou si on avait
une petite marge de liberté je parle pas
de la corée du nord mais je ne sais pas
prendre prenons le venezuela par exemple
si on a une petite marge de liberté
fatalement nous allons d'abord enquêter
sur ce pouvoir centralisateur étatique
il se trouve que dans nos sociétés à
nous c'est le pouvoir des entreprises
qui pose question à beaucoup de niveaux
d'ailleurs dans tous les grands thèmes
qui traversent notre civilisation
aujourd'hui l'environnement
l'intelligence artificielle
la concentration des richesses voilà
alors on prend des risques non vous
prenez pas de risques en l'invitant lui
et puis de toute façon ça dépend de ce
que nous ce que ce que jean pierre canet
dira cours de cette interview de ce que
je dirai moi mais c'est pas en
l'invitant lui que tu prendrais un
risque c'est pas comme ça tu es soumis
compte tenu de la manière dont
fonctionne
tata chaîne très très exactement à la
loi de 1881 et dont les limites sont la
diffamation et l'injure peut-être
que tu es soumis exactement aux mêmes
règles que jean-pierre les et j'aurais
récusé le procès en tête brûlée qui lui
est fait s'il n'avait pas fait lui-même
parce qu'on a déjà eu l'occasion de se
croiser beaucoup et de travailler
ensemble et en fait il se trouve que je
suis assis à côté d'un vrai journaliste
alors que ce soit très emmerdant un vrai
journal m'en fous journaliste ben c'est
un peu ce qu'ils décrivaient c'est à
dire que je n'étais pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que tu es là où je
voulais je vous laisse un terrain peu
masi un journaliste qui va faire des
ménages ce qui était interdit et ce qui
semble être un peu moi tu vois bien quel
hypocrisie parce que on te dit dans
[raclement de gorge]
la version en t on te dit un journaliste
n'a pas le droit d'aller faire des
ménages c'est-à-dire comme jean-pierre
l'indiqué allait animer des conventions
corporate tu vois des conventions
d'entreprise des choses comme ça mais en
revanche je n'ai pas de difficulté à ce
qu'une banque soit au capital d'une
chaîne de télé ou d'un journal oui ou
d'un journal ou fait que ce soit une
banque ou une grosse industrie est ce
que décrivent et jean-pierre à l'instant
ça existait avant mais la contrainte
qu'on ressentait quand on était dans des
dossiers où on avait besoin de faire
sortir une information quel que soit le
dossier c'est que je parle je parle
avant ces grosses concentrations tycoon
donc juste avant le la phase que tu que
tu décrivez là c'est que les boîtes les
entreprises commerciales industrielles
financières étaient annonceurs et donc
déjà c'était déjà un problème maintenant
que grand nombre des médias
appartiennent à ces sociétés là tu
imagines que le tamis de l'information
est devenue très très très très serré
jean-pierre par l'aide des
programmations en train de gérer le
dossier de déprogrammation qui est tout
à fait lié à aux mécanismes qui viennent
d'être décrit mes dents dans le
le même type de sujet on voit très bien
quels sont les pressions qui sont
exercées pour contenir pour encapsuler
une information etc elles et qu'elles ne
sortent pas si tu savais le nombre de
ses
confrères qui nous appelle on les
obtient on va faire un sujet sur tel ou
tel de votre nouveau dossier sur lequel
vous bossez et puis la première question
qu'on pose parce qu'on connaît un peu la
musique à force c'est mais ça a été
validée en conférence de rédaction nous
dit oui très bien et l'actionnaire est
au courant de ça on nous dit non mais ne
t'inquiète pas ça passera ne vous
inquiétez pas ça passera et puis
finalement le sujet et râpé alors il est
râpé plus ou moins tôt selon
que les instances dirigeantes de la
chaîne se rendre compte plus ou moins
tôt mais mais la mécanique demeure quand
même la même et c'est pour ça que on est
de plus en plus quand on n'est pas dans
un sujet ultra tu vois dans une démarche
ultraman stream à venir dans des médias
comme les vôtres ici il
n'y a pas de sujets qui sont rappelés
chez mediapart à ma connaissance en tout
cas moi je n'ai jamais vécu ça chez eux
alors que nous avons beaucoup
[raclement de gorge] travaillé avec eux
alors qu'un canal par exemple bon bah
voilà c'est presque l'exemple presque
trois ans leur on l'a vu non seulement
la vue mais en plus on l'a on l'a
vu on l'a vu de nos yeux sont ils tu
sens que tu sens plus rien en fait avec
ta toute une équipe qui est à fond pour
faire un sujet ils ont calibre et ils
ont lors ils ont leur feuille de route
ils ont obtenu les accords des gens qui
sont concernés puis d'un coup ça
s'arrête et tu reçois un sms sont audi
bon désolé sais
pas d'où ça vient d'euros et c'est réglé
l'un des lanceurs dallaire du crédit
mutuel nous avait dit bien en amont
quand on a commencé l'enquète le l'un
des trois lanceurs dallaire de du crédit
mutuel nous de la faire du crédit mutuel
nous avait dit m et vous savez que le
crédit mutuel a à quelques pourcentages
dans canal+ or c'est vrai que cris
mutuel à quelques pourcentages dans
canal+ au moment où on démarre l'anc est
très peu on
lui répond donc ils pensent ils
s'inquiètent nous dit mais ce sujet va
pas passer on raconte dans le bouquet
est d'ailleurs et nous
on lui répond la bouche en coeur avec
nicolas et avec geoffrey livolsi on lui
répond
surtout non ça va pas c'est qu'elle
n'est plus ok ya eu quelques soubresauts
ça fait quelques années parfois nos
sujets ne passe pas mais non ça va
passer il n'y a aucun risque et la
véraison third alerte en fait est là où
je voudrais rebondir sur ce qu'ils
disent sur ce qu'on disait à l'instant
c'est que on est dans une situation
quand même très paradoxale où
aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut prendre
la parole sur internet a raconté
n'importe quoi et à intel une telle
masse de désinformation
de diffamation qui passe tous les jours
sans aucun procès n'est rien ou sur des
gros dossiers comme ceux ci là où on
prend tous des risques on dit un petit
mot de travers on fait en sorte du trait
de seconde on peut se prendre un procès
en diffamation
et quand il s'agit de vincent bolloré on
se prend en france qu'on appelle une
procédure bâillon un bâillon mais un
bâillon sur laon mais un bâillon sur le
la bouche du journaliste et ses
procédures bâillon elle l'a vincent
bolloré la halle à activer pour ce
bouquin sur nicolas veskovac szymon
coauteur l'idée est de tuer l'enquète
avant même qu'elles sortent c'est à dire
c'est une autre interprétation ça à ben
non c'est sûr que c'est ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya une vingtaine de journalistes
sont qui ont été poursuivies ou qui sont
poursuivis par vincent bolloré
aujourd'hui une quarantaine de médias de
mémoire en tout depuis quelques années
qu'ils sont poursuivis par vincent
bolloré sur
des affaires que d'ailleurs souvent il
perd au tribunal sur [grognement]
les affaires africaines notamment ils
attendent beaucoup là dessus mais avec
nous innovation il attaque il ya un an
et qu'on avait ce covaci reçoit la
visite d'un huissier
pourquoi [grognement]
parce que nicolas avait tout simplement
fait le travail comme joris doivent
faire c'est à dire le [grognement]
principe du contradictoire vous avez
rassemblé des informations vous appelez
la personne qui mise en cause ou qu'en
tout cas à qui on a des questions à
poser il a envoyé de mémoire 22 mai il a
une douzaine de personnes dont vincent
bolloré la direction de vivendi et de
canal+ je crois que 14 sms et on lui a
répondu que c'était du harcèlement mais
on lui a pas répondu au téléphone on lui
envoyer un huissier et on lui réclame
700 mille euros un an avant la sortie du
livre s'est pas beaucoup non c'est non
c'est vrai on peut dire on va faire une
collecte non je rigole ne partez pas sur
ce qu'il faut que tu mesures la danse
comme dit jean pierre sexy son confrère
n'avait pas fait ce qui vient d'être
décrit alors il était en faute tellement
aussi bien du point de vue de la bonne
foi qui est attachée aux procédures
contre des journalistes ou contre des
supports de presse en matière de
diffamation qu'en
termes de déontologie des journalistes
où il doit donner le contrepoint tu vois
si la silla un angle s'il a un axe il
doit absolument aller chercher le
contrechamp ça c'est leur déontologie
sinon ce sont des reportages à charge
donc c'est assez intéressant d'entendre
la et moi j'ai découvert dans la presse
comme tout le monde mais c'est un
dossier dans lequel je ne suis pas
impliqué mais
c'est assez intéressant de voir que la
bonne manière de faire devient une
manière qui est poursuivi dans ce que tu
entres dans ce qu'on entend là c'est
exactement ça les procédures bâillon
conti p1 est ce qu'il faudrait pas un
petit peu travaillé au niveau de la
justice pour sip
et qu'il utilise trouve là un abus de
justice relève alors ça s'appelle pas
comme ça le sera pleinement mis civile
mais ça existe mais si tu veux en
matière de trois outils en matière de
droit de la presse c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment que c'est une broutille c'est
que tous
les comptes à toute les tous
les niveaux d'indemnisation de victimes
d'infractions de presse sont très très
bas que ce soit en matière d'atteinte à
la vie privée que ce soit en matière d'
injure que ce soit en matière de
diffamation et a fortiori aujourd'hui ou
bon si tu te faisais diffamer ou injurié
par un journaliste qui était agacé après
toi en 1995 battu passé quinze jours un
peu pénible où on avait entendu parler
de toi maintenant c'est indélébile donc
si tu veux la manière de je crois que la
société notamment le droit n'est pas
encore au niveau de la tente quand il ya
réellement une infraction presse qui est
caractérisée à l'endroit de l'homme nos
clients ou ou même à l'endroit d'un
journaliste d'où la situation paradoxale
c'est à dire qu'en fait on peut diffamer
comme on veut sans rien risquer et puis
d'un autre côté quand on essaye de
travailler à peu près sérieusement en
vérifiant des informations c'est le
salon de faire une enquête et on y passe
des nuits on ne paye c'est normal on est
payé pour ça c'est normal mais du coup
là on se prend des procédures bâillon et
du coup qu'est ce qui se passe et a
beaucoup de journalistes qui n'osent
plus aller enquêter parce qu'ils n'ont
pas envie de bouffer la baraque est pire
que ça les rédactions je vous rappelle
que aujourd'hui on est un petit peu
comme dans le bâtiment et beaucoup de
sous traitance dans le monde de
l'audiovisuel
ces boîtes de prod qui travaillent
d'ailleurs la preuve nous a quand même
c'est ce qu'on faisait en produisait un
reportage pour canal + en sont repartis
le risque mais oui qui porte un pacte en
partie le risque donc c'est de l'argent
donc pourquoi ces des procédures qui
fatigue l'anc est parce qu on dépense de
l'argent on paie un avocat qui souvent
est sympa parce que il va nous faire un
prix spécial qui sait que ça va durer
quelques mois mais simplement mais c'est
parce qu'il est sympa ça va durer
combien de temps tu es en train de ses
centrales pas de lui non non pas du tout
mais parce qu'on n'est pas du tout en
affaires il faut bien que les gens le
sachent mais simplement sinon leur a dit
si on aurait dit mais simplement ce
travail là pendant que vous êtes en
train de répondre à ça eh bien vous ne
travaillez pas sur le fond vous ne fait
pas avancer d'autres dossiers donc ouais
c'est une manière de tuer
l'investigation gilles à l'enlisement
oui parce qu est-ce que vous avez été
amené à monter des structures dirai ce
que est ce que vous montez une équipe
d'avocats pour vous suivre pendant qu
est ce que david a entendu parler de
salles américaines s'étaient alors tu
sais il s'agit pas pardon il s'agit pas
de monter une équipe mais on est on est
un certain nombre d'avocats jomphe est
parti à travailler au service de
journalistes qui veulent valider non pas
la pertinence de l'information parce que
l'information si tu veux ils l'ont dans
leurs mains une information c'est qu'en
deux à trois sources disent la même
chose avant ça c'est une rumeur ce
qu'ils veulent c'est confirmait que
l'information existe bien en tant que
tel et donc nous ce qu'on va regarder c6
est attaquable ou pas et en fonction de
l'instruction qui nous est donné on fait
ça très très souvent pour beaucoup de
journalistes c'est d'amener la formation
le plus loin possible à la limite de de
l'ata câble ou plus exactement de
l'inattaquable tu vois mais à la limite
haute de l'inattaquable parce qu'il en
va de la manière tu vois il en va de la
forme bah oui c'est ça dans compostons
cabinet comment tu dis quoi comment se
compose mon cabinet aujourd'hui qui
[raclement de gorge] travaille chez toi
un des avocats on est un peu plus d'une
vingtaine au sein du cabinet 28 octobre
il
y a des départements il y a notamment un
département très actif en droit de la
presse et en risque médias c'est à dire
que bon temps après je pense que tu
comprends et tout le monde comprend ce
que c'est le risque médias c'est une
matière un peu nouvelle qui fait un peu
écho à ce que disait jean-pierre ici où
des hommes politiques ou des
journalistes ou des éditeurs viennent
nous voir et nous ment date pour savoir
jusqu'où précisément ils peuvent aller
pour
n'être pas attaquer parce que pardon
d'être un peu grossier mais derrière
toutes ces activités il ya un modèle
économique je sais que dès qu'on parle
d'argent c'est un vrai sujet mais il ya
un modèle économique et dans une boîte
de prod qui fait de la mastication dans
un journal d'investigation
il y a également un modèle économique et
donc s'il devait y avoir un procès par
sujet ce modèle économique ce cas serait
purement et simplement la gueule donc
l'idée de ces gens là est une bonne idée
est d'aller voir des avocats qui
apposent leur signature en bas d'une
consultation qui les engage donc en
termes de responsabilité
on leur dit aux termes de la loi aux
termes de la jurisprudence applicable la
jurisprudence c'est-à-dire les décisions
qui sont rendues par les juges tous les
jours partout en france dans la matière
en question il ya des bases qui publie
cette jurisprudence là vous pouvez aller
jusque là où vous ne pouvez pas y aller
parce que ça a déjà été condamné dans
quel sens où ça n'est pas condamnable
dont l autre donc voilà la manière dont
ça fonctionne et allant au delà au sein
du cabinet 28 octobre que j'ai cofondé
avec benoît pruvost il y a de cela une
quinzaine d'années nous venons
d'être rejoint par je suis absolument
ravi de te l'annoncé par jean de
maillard qui est un extraordinaire
professionnel tu connais qui est un
ancien magistrat et qui est l'ancien
vice président du tribunal de grande
instance de paris et qui s'est intéressé
sa vie professionnelle durant à toutes
les formes de lutte contre toutes les
formes de détournement de fonds d'abus
de confiance de
prise illégale d'intérêt ben tu vois
bien l'angle qui là qu'il a donné à sa
carrière et il travaille aujourd'hui
avec nous au sein du cabinet et il y
travaille aux côtés d'un ancien policier
financier d'un ancien régulateur et d'un
ancien procureur de la république et
nous montons là pour la peine une vraie
cellule forces au service des
particuliers et des entreprises pour
pouvoir
parvenir à borner ce qu'il est possible
de faire et ce qui n'est pas possible de
faire et puis également et surtout pour
faire défense un certain nombre de
d'attac qui nous semblent nous
totalement hallucinante et quand une
entreprise n'a pas les moyens d'y faire
face en général elle est arrêtée net
parce que ce que décrit jean pierre là
ça existe aussi dans le monde de
l'entreprise ça n'est pas que dans la
manière de fabriquer de faire circuler
l'information qu'on retrouve ça on
retrouve ce genre de procès donc voilà
ce qu'on est en train de faire depuis
quelques mois et c'est c'est assez
passionnant parce que c'est c'est un
nouveau champ de pratique qui
se dessine sous nos yeux au fur et à
mesure où on avance quoi il est normal
que nous soyons que l'opinion publique
et puis les gens sur lesquels les
enquêtes portent je précise que c'est
toujours d enquête qui porte sur des
sujets d'intérêt public en voit rarement
sur la vie privée sauf quand elles
débouchent comme on le voit en ce moment
sur sur des questions d'intérêt public
il est normal qu'on soit redevable
d'être très précis dans la formation est
normal qu'on soit exigeant sur la
vérification des faits c'est le minimum
vital
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il ya même des
lacunes dans pas mal de parfois de dents
dans des pratiques journalistiques un
peu rapide le contradictoire et pas
toujours appliquée etc c'est normal en
revanche il n'est pas normal que nous
soyons aujourd'hui dans une situation où
nous ayons de plus en plus le couteau
sous la gorge ça c'est pas normal bon le
droit nous protège clairement mais les
pratiques sont en train clairement de
bouger et pour faire écho à ce que dit
david on a nous depuis des années un
cash investigations là partout moi en
tout cas j'ai travaillé à cash
investigations à pièces à conviction
avant à canal déjà où je pense que
mediapart c'est pareil ou monde bien sûr
qu'on travaille avec des avocats en
amont en amont des enquêtes pour
vérifier que les formulations soient les
bonnes et c'est donc le travail commun
des avocats et des juristes avec les
journalistes ouais c'est devenu vraiment
une pratique courante et c'est normal
aussi mais faut bien comprendre que
cette économie effectivement est fragile
il ya de l'argent pour enquêter le
service public par exemple paye des
enquêtes à l'extérieur et aussi en
interne avec un budget qui est
acceptable mais c'est une économie très
fragile les ans les investigations c'est
que des emmerdes passez moi l'expression
c'est beaucoup de pression ces deux là
c'est de la mise en cause au sens
on va interroger des intérêts donc oui
c'est une économie très fragile mais ça
n'est pas qu'une économie c est aussi et
avant tout un contre-pouvoir nécessaire
à la démocratie voilà tu parles de
contre-pouvoir le docteur en droit qui
était apte à gauche docteur
[raclement de gorge] en droit dumont en
droit de la presse qu'est ce qui se
passe au niveau de notre démocratie si
la presse ce votre ton avis là dessus ça
n'est plus une démocratie on sait ce
qu'on est encore en démocratie non tu
sais bien que non non non mais très
sérieusement d'un cheval sexy je ne
pense pas [grognement] mais il se plante
pourquoi j'essaye d'y croire mais enfin
tu sais il ya quelque chose d'un peu
d'un peu simple à dire et qui est
facilement vérifiable c'est que le
fondement même d'une démocratie le
pilier le pilier central d'une
démocratie c'est l'indépendance de la
justice avant même de parler de la
liberté d'information et c'est donc dès
lors qu'on est en mesure de prouver que
la justice française n'est pas
indépendante et c'est chiant à dire mais
elle ne l'est pas et d'ailleurs lors
de la sortie de mon précédent bouquin
une contestation française j'ai fait un
certain nombre de deux plateaux il ya eu
un certain nombre de papiers autour de
ça je dis ça personne n'a rien attaqué
personne [raclement de gorge] absolument
rien attaque et il n'est pas rare non
plus qu'on fasse des petits déjeuners de
travail avec d'anciens ministres mais
mes récents un pad et tu vois des
ministres sous pompidou giscard qui te
disent mais oui je les lui je suis
d'accord avec ça et ça c'est encore plus
déprimante tout le reste c'est vrai
parce que tu aimerais bien les
rencontrer dans une manière de off où
ils te dirai quand je ne suis pas
d'accord mais ils sont d'accord avec çà
et donc si la justice n'est pas
indépendante on n'est pas en démocratie
coup il laisse faire tu
veux dire le gouvernement les
gouvernements les ministres qui voit
qu'ils sont d'accord un gay parce que le
pouvoir n'est pas la sky le pouvoir
n'est pas là du tout ça c'est un apparat
moi je moi j'ai une très bonne solution
qui nous permettrait d'allier nous nos
deux expertises c'est de mettre des
caméras à l'elysée dans les ministères
et en faire un show télé tu vois en
faisant croire aux gens que c'est là que
ça se passait en leur disant la manière
dont
les choses se passent et puis on filmera
le conseil des ministres ou vers l est
les flonflons à la française parce que
c'est très français tout ça et puis on
dirait aux gens dans le même temps ça
c'est du divertissement pour la vraie
vie pour les vraies décisions ça se
passe au sein des boîtes du cac 40 dans
les banques dans nos industries dans la
presse aujourd'hui mais pas dans la
manière qui plaît à jean pierre est ce
qu'il ya une chose qui est très simple
il ya il ya une infographie qui a
circulé qui était je crois publié par
libé ou envoyer un éclaté de la manière
dont tous les groupes de presse qui
connaissent je crois que c'est le monde
diplomatique sa sortie ça et libellules
reprendre mais je l'avais vue et tu
voyais à qui appartenaient tous les
groupes de presse français est en fait
tu te rends compte que 90% des groupes
de presse français donc de la presse
donc de la manière dont l'information
est fabriquée circulent comme on disait
tout à l'heure à partir à une dizaine de
milliardaires il ya un truc est quand
même assez incroyable c'est que si tu
veux placer des avoirs bancaires tu peux
aller vers des banquiers mais si tu veut
consommer de l'information il vaut quand
même mieux aller vers des journalistes
dans la vraie vie c'est curieux que des
gens qui ont un poids économique
monumentale à y acheter des
fans
de prince qui sont le plus souvent
déficitaires donc c'est quoi ça serait
part par amour de la presse et du droit
de la presse et non c'est pas ça on
trouve sur le sur le sujet des ados
reste racine kane sur le sujet de la
démocratie la chose me semble simple et
je défend cette position je crois que
nous serons en démocratie quand nos
dirigeants seront sanctionnés de la même
manière que le sont nos concitoyens et
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas si tu
veux être en démocratie il faut que nous
posions ensemble pour faire promulguer
une loi aux termes de laquelle comtois
élu de la république et lui via le
suffrage universel
tu es pris avec les doigts dans le pot
de confiture en train de détourner des
fonds publics on veut nous citoyens
français que tu sois condamné sûreté
deniers personnels et que deux tu soit
inéligible à vie pour le dire autrement
si tu nous flou on te punit et ça c'est
pas très compliqué de faire cette loi
dira si les gens qui nous gouvernent ont
besoin dead
pour la rédiger je suis sûr que cannes
et les aidera et puis tu auras koubbi
qui ira avec lui pour les ayants droit
et pour les aider mais non mais tu vois
c'est très simple dire si on part en
vacances tous les to les six là dans le
studio et que tu es en comment
dirais-je en charge de faire des courses
et qu'on te donne 50 euros chacun et que
tu rentres avec deux croissants tous les
jours on va très vite comprendre que tu
détourne ça sera plus toi qui va faire
les courses sky depuis la fois d'après
tu partiras plus en vacances avec nous
parce que tu seras à sale petit [__]
de voleurs de l'argent de course jenny
qui jamais n'ont jamais un exemple
celles et à ceux des cols non mais tu
vois il a raison alors ça c'est un vrai
bon exemple en gros si on prend une
autre une autre image
on peut pas acheter un média et puis re
décider des lois du journalisme en fait
enfin des droits de la presse c'est trop
en gros on peut pas avoir des voitures
vendre des voitures électriques par
exemple et réinventer le code de la
route fait depuis un petit moment non
mais c'est simple en fait c'est qu'on
peut pas tout on peut pas tout et donc
on est une fois de plus ce pardon je
suis un peu en boucle pas tous puissent
mais ce qu'il dit on est d'accord sur la
démocratie moi je dis simplement qu'on
n'est pas en russie ou en turquie
quoique russie on a fait mieux que
william pas non mais on n' ya pas encore
de danger de
mort la presse est libre en france on
peut travailler mais simplement ce
qui fait quand même une très grosse
différence avec des gens qui ont eu
recours à la nature dont par exemple à
redon je reviens tu peux travailler mais
quand ton reportage dérange il a des
programmes nommer lui-même a conduit on
le paye cash enfin je dire je ne vais
pas raconter ma petite histoire mais on
en a plein d histoire bien sûr qu'on le
paye cher quand on tient tête bien
entendu je vois tête et on comprend vite
mais simplement ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que on a on a en fait on est en
fait on est dans une situation de dérive
voilà on dérive lentement effectivement
les pouvoirs qui sont les plus
importants aujourd'hui ne sont pas
interrogées et ne sont pas assez
contrôlé ses seins et ils indépendants
non mais c'est ça il est inexistant il
sert pas à grand chose voilà tu poses la
question du csa prenons
prenons un exemple que je connais très
bien auquel je suis en train de
m'intéresser l'attribution de la chaîne
numéro 23 c'était
une c'était une matière gratuite
cette chaîne nasa a été attribué à la
suite d'un appel d'offres nous dit haut
et ça a été revendu 100 millions d'euros
on n'a même pas un sujet sur les
finances publiques sur les deniers
publics ici ça et qui attribue le csa
qui donne l'autorisation d'émettre le
csa je pense que la réponse à ta
question enfin tu sais il faut pas leur
embêter ces gens du csa alors là moi
pour la peine je peux parce que j'ai pas
deux donc j'ai pas de sujet mais toi toi
aussi évidemment mais
quand
on parle de la mf de l'autorité des
marchés financiers ta question est ce
que le csa est indépendant et la mfc et
indépendant toutes
les autorités qui sont des autorités de
régulation comme ça dans la vraie vie si
on était dans une société un peu pensé
un peu cohérente avec un peu moins
d'hypocrisie quand nous aurions des
opérateurs mais c'est vraiment une
hypothèse d'école ce que je dis
n'arrivera jamais parce que ça voudrait
dire que nous entrerions en démocratie
mais si nous étions dans une hypothèse
où certains opérateurs devenait déviant
dans la vraie vie il serait empêcher de
nuire donc empêché de recommencer leur
licence leur permettant de continuer
leurs activités alors serait retirée or
tu n'entends jamais parlé de ça il ya
des sanctions qui sont des pouliches
pardon pour le terme mais quand une
banque prend 4 millions d'euros d'amendé
par
la mfs
voix j'entends les bouchons de champagne
ce devait être débouchées scandale du
libre de l'euribor et je te parle je te
pardonne tout ça à la fois pour la peine
on travaille dans ce dans ce sujet pour
un certain nombre de deux
boucs émissaires parce qu'il ya pas
d'autres mots le tube tu parles du
scandale de libor et de l'euribor qui
est le plaignant personne n'y a pas de
gagnant qui est la victime y'en a pas un
sou nous on sait pas mais j'ai tué la
victime à la condition qu'ils aient un
dommage qu'elle ait le dommage il n'est
pas démontré quel est le montant du
préjudice on n'en sait rien donc c'est
devenu le scandale du libor et de
l'euribor mais en définitive je crois
qu'on devrait regarder à londres où je
me rends souvent es tu le sais pour
travailler dans ce sujet la manière dont
dont marche le s est fausse et sérieuse
fraude fait c'est l'équivalent du
ministère public qui serait
des sortes de procureur financier et je
pense que ces gens là font leur statut
sur un scandale qui n'existent pas
c'était des pratiques bancaires tu vois
je suis d'une absolue bonne foi si je
pouvais enfin tu vois si j'étais dans
une forme de pathologie qui consiste à
cogner systématiquement sur les banques
je te le dirai c'est pas ça il y avait
des pratiques c'était autorisé au bout
d'un moment on a dit c'est pas que c'est
illégal c'est que c'est un scandale tu
vois les gens se se parlait le fait qu'
il cale l'étau ensemble c'était
comme ça que ça fonctionne et est à
partir d'un moment on n'a pas 17
interdit on a dit c'est un scandale et
donc on est tous partis sur c'est un
scandale moi le premier pendant des
années jusqu'à ce que je comprenne
comment ça commence à ça fonctionne mais
ça tu sais je crois que c'est des petits
hochet médiatique qu'ont qu'on
jette adea des toutous comme lui à des
toutous comme moi pour qu'on a il
s'occupait puis
qu'on fasse pas trop chier le csa tu
parles du csa le csa moi j'ai rien
contre les gens du csa sauf que là
l'institution n'est pas du tout calibré
pour contrôler les atteintes aux droits
de la presse par exemple
là il a fallu je ne sais combien de
liste de sujets problématiques pour
qu'il ait enfin un reportage
probablement une peut-être une publicité
déguisée en reportage à la gloire du
président gnassingbé en tout cas du togo
soit étudiée par le csa c'est peut-être
15e sujet depuis que vincent bolloré a
pris le contrôle le canal + pour
qu'enfin le cssa se saisissent delà de
la question nous quand on est allé les
voir avec notre collectif informer n'est
pas un délit qui regroupe plusieurs
journalistes d'investigation de la
presse on [grognement]
avait les preuves étaient sur la table
il ne les voyait pas et ils nous ont ils
ont fini par nous dire mais on peut rien
faire on n'est pas calibré pour ça alors
j'ai entendu on veut une petite descente
d'organes non mais ce qu'il ya c'est que
c'est un peu désespérant moi c'est pas
moi en fait moi on s'en fout de moi on
s'en fout de nous ce qui compte c'est
que le citoyen français soit un tout
petit peu
protégé par des institutions en fait
c'est que l'information à laquelle il a
droit soient protégés ont sorti de la
rue il ya le drone est ce qu il ne fut
enfin alors ça c'est une autre question
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas non plus qu'on
soit nous dans une démarche de il ya les
méchants hop il est gentil en banon
c'est un jeu cdc des choix de société
c'est vrai que on a on dit souvent qu'on
a les institutions et les politiques
qu'on mérite c'est vrai c'est dû mais ça
c'est une question quasi philosophique
c'est une question profonde de caisse
que notre société aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on on parle de démocratie
participative par exemple qui sera un
bon moyen de réguler trouver des moyens
de contre-pouvoir dans les faits quand
un maire un petit maire dans un bled
instaure la démocratie participative
ça marche pas toujours bien quoi c'est à
dire qu'on a toujours autre chose à
faire alors et on va pas y passer nos
vies non plus mais c'est vrai que
vouloir
une année tu as moins centralisée
vouloir des vrai contre-pouvoir c'est
aussi des choix politiques clairement
l'europe il les protège un peu peut pas
du tout aux journalistes ouais l'union
européenne les médias c'est quoi c'est
maintenant l'europe dicte des des grands
principes aussi sur internet 1 et
ensuite c'est pas grave on peut répondre
quand même internet fait partie de notre
vie c'était l'europe édicte des grands
principes et ensuite ils sont transcrits
en droit le cas l'endroit nationale en
l'espace on en droit français et enfin
je ne sens pas une protection c'est
un peu plus protecteur uvn le whif à la
condition d'aller faire fonctionner la
teinte là bas ce qui est une procédure
oui exactement qui revient tu vois du
groupe acp ue métier compliqué et puis
ne serait-ce que d'autres d'autres lois
d'autres directives ça s'appelle comme
ça une loi européenne c'est une
directive qui appliquez ensuite dans les
pays européens membres de l'union
européenne la directive sur le secret
des affaires sur laquelle nous avons
combattu pareil avec le collectif
pendant
trois ans on en voit les conséquences
aujourd'hui les conséquences aujourd'hui
c'est que malgré le fait que des ong
notre collectif des syndicats rsf
reporters sans frontières se soit
abattue pour diminuer la violence de
ceux de cette directive qui consiste en
gros à classer toute une série
d'informations comme étant secrète par
essence et à criminaliser le lanceur
d'alerté lançant hertz est ni plus ni
moins qu'une source quelqu'un qui voit
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans une
dans une entreprise jusqu'à
présent était plus que même s'il y avait
un vrai déficit de d'encadrement
juridique avait plutôt le droit de son
côté s'il n'était pas en train
d'utiliser les informations qu'il a à
des fins personnelles mais qu'il les
révéler par exemple à la presse pour
s'enrichir effectivement la
directive sur le secret des affaires
vient criminaliser ça et on commence à
en voir les premières conséquences
aujourd'hui donc voilà c'est une
bataille c'est en cinq ans on est quand
même en démocratie c'est que c'est
directive contre une autre directive
c'est la femme du débat on est là on
parlait d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que
ça va pas dans le bon sens petite
question le [raclement de gorge] des
codex vous entoure vous en pensez quoi
l'aider codex l'effet que nous s'il
effectue opéré par la prend pas des
connexions déconnexions pose des
questions non mais non mais par contre
l'effet que news bon là aujourd'hui nous
est codé que ça non non je surpris les
ong demandent pourquoi on bosse que je
n'ai pas d'avis parce que peut-on /
lesure exactement non non non mais on
n'est pas non mais on peut pas avoir un
avis sur tout en fait il faut travailler
les choses j'ai pas la vie ce soir
pardon pardon tout loupé me doute bien
que si on avait un truc intelligent est
à te dire sur des codecs sont eux le
dirai tout cas pas se concentrer
vraiment sur la vous qu'elle a d'un coup
donc [rires]
pas les 5 news on peut en parler donc
l'effet que nous les fake news donc
aujourd'hui c'est une journée
particulière puisque ça y est le
gouvernement sort ses propositions il
faut regarder ça dans le détail on va
pas commenter ça parce qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de choses qui vont évoluer mais
est ce que la question c'est est-ce
qu'un autorités politiques et en est en
charge doit elle proposer
une loi pour contrôler l'information
c'est de ça dont on parle parce qu'une
fée news pour certain bien sûr qu'il ya
des faits que nous aurait réel et
terminaux portuaires gt1 mais il ya
aussi toute une série d'informations qui
sont pour certains des faits news pour
d'autres pas il ya tout le temps ça peut
être aussi l'occasion de de jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est à dire tel
média j'ai entendu dire qu a priori
horaires un contrôle assez importants
sur la nature des médias notamment
quelques semaines avant les élections
encore une fois je parle prudemment je
connais pas les détails mais
ça c'est inquiétant parce que on va
faire un tri en fait il va se passer
quoi il ya un truc qui est très simple
pour pour nom mais il faut le dire aux
gens qui nous écoutent il faut qu'il le
répète partout notamment dans les écoles
et un truc très simple en fait il faut
appliquer de trois règles pour savoir à
qui qu'ils s'adressent à nous en tant
que média est ce que le média en
question vérifier ces informations est
ce qu'il ya des sources est ce qu'elles
sont sûres c'est précisément de
multiples sources et une information à
plusieurs sources est-ce qu'on peut donc
nous mêmes allés vérifier ce que le
journaliste à vérifier est ce que on a
des témoins qui corroborent ce qui est
dit ou est-ce qu'on est dans le fantasme
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on raconte nous
quand on va intervenir dans les collèges
ou les lycées juste après charlie hebdo
on a beaucoup fait ça il ya quelques
règles en fait pour bien lutter contre
l'effet que ni aux il faudrait créer un
peu d'enseignements sur qu'est-ce que
l'information dans les écoles alors il
ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans les
écoles en
droit français il n'existe pas de
sanction pour la divulgation d'une
information qui est fausse donc
si je te dis femmes publiquement tu peux
me poursuivre et tu gagneras si je t'ai
dit fermer si je tends le jury au
titre de la loi de 1881 de juillet 1881
qui fonde la liberté de la presse mais
également qu'il aborde
je serai puni si je perds je riais en
revanche si je dis que j'ai déjeuné avec
toi la semaine dernière et que ce n'est
pas vrai et que ça te causant préjudice
ça n'est pas par cette mécanique
juridique de la divulgation d'une fausse
information que tu pourra obtenir
réparation et
donc là on est en train de nous dire que
il va en définitive y avoir une vérité
si on comprend bien puisque la loi n'est
pas promulguée elle n'est pas
d'application aujourd'hui mais si on
comprend bien on est en train de vous
dire en creux a contrario qu'il va y
avoir un délit de divulgation de fake
news et qu'est ce qui intéresse les gens
qui sont en train de fabriquer cette loi
c'est bien évidemment le moment des
élections
jean-pierre l'a esquissé surtout si ce
qu'ils appellent la propagande de
détails extérieurs c'est ça donc là on
est en train de rebondir
mais je sais pas si c'est une bonne idée
ou une fausse bonne idée mais il est
trop tôt pour le dire puisque on verra
ce que dira le texte ce qu'il faut
regarder le faut regarder ce dont on
parle mais on en train de nous dire que
des états étrangers pourraient venir
peser sur l'élection c'est ça qu'on
comprend et si c'est ça qui est
sanctionné et qui doit être évitée bien
tant mieux c'est une bonne nouvelle si
maintenant c'est un cheval de troie et
moi ma préoccupation est là pour valider
pour venir dire à des gars comme lui ou
des gars comme nous quand on les défend
on quand on les attaque d'ailleurs parce
que les deux points de vue se valent
tout à fait tu vois mais si c'est pour
venir nous dire ça vous n'avez pas le
droit de le dire ça n'est pas la vérité
il faudra qu'on réponde bien à la
question de ce qu'est la vérité parce
que j'ai peut-être pas le même point de
vue que toi ans que jean pierre sueur
tel était le sujet et je peux voir une
vérité quelque part là où tu vois toi
une contre-vérité inversement or le
débat public et le débat démocratique
suppose que l'on puisse encore un tout
petit peu écrire ce qu'on pensait penser
ce qu'on a envie de penser qu'en colline
powell en 2003 juste avant de lancer la
guerre en irak à l'onu brandi la menace
des armes de destruction massive de
saddam hussein a priori pour pas mal de
médias grand des grands médias
américains c'est une vérité
vérifiez français aussi et france ou et
moi un peu moins mais enfin oui ou non
mais il y en a plein de casseroles 1
mais simplement là on peut pas dire que
la france était fière au nom très forts
de cette intervention et bas quelques
années plus tard la
révélation de certain nombre de
documents secrets notamment de la nes
avons révélé qu' il n'y avait pas de
justification très forte à cette guerre
voilà donc d'un côté on avait affaire
une information qui est devenue une fête
news après vérifier et entre-temps
imagine-toi imagine toi on est à
l'époque
on a un blog d'information gratte un peu
on va vérifier à gauche à droite avec
nos sources et on tombe sur ça et on le
marque noir sur blanc sur le site et là
il ya un des codex qui décolle qui nous
met une petite pastille rouge mais
tant qu'on n'aura pas pardonner tant les
temps qu'on n'aurait pas vu la manière
dont la loi sera rédigé dans sa version
finale sera il sera difficile de
répondre à ta question mais tu sais
avant ça dans un usage plus quotidiens
et de l'information fin au confluent de
l'information et du droit il ya une
chose qui peut te préoccuper qui moi me
préoccupe qui devrait préoccuper nos
législateurs
d'une manière un peu plus urgente que
qu'est-ce qui est la vraie information
et casques à la faille news c'est que le
délai pour attaquer au titre du droit de
la presse sur la diffamation par exemple
et de trois mois à compter de la
publication de la parution de
l'information dans
des grands dossiers médiatico judiciaire
qui fabrique des grands brûlés
médiatico-judiciaire quel qu'il soit
quant à eux partent avec ce qu'on
appelle dans notre milieu pour ce qu'il
a de commun la meute sur une information
toi tu as pas fait de votre news mais
non mais si tu vois tu vois très bien
partie de la meute bien entendu donc par
tad su et qu'on dit il a assassiné sa
femme ou son mari et caetera et
l'assassin a ceci cela l'assassin pas le
meurtrier est toujours un meurtrier
c'est quelqu'un qui a tué un assassin
[raclement de gorge] c'est quelqu'un qui
a tué avec préméditation et que le
bonhomme dont il est question à
l'issue d'un périple crois-moi épuisant
qui le mène à la cour d'assises est
blanchi bien le délai pour attaquer
toutes ces informations qui ont été
propagées
sur lui qui était donc fausse je veux
dire puisqu'il ya une vérité judiciaire
a tous moi ce délai est expiré donc tu
vois on pourrait aussi réfléchir aux
prescription en la matière parce que
trois mois pour faire valoir ses droits
alors qu'ils envoient de qu'il en va de
ton image qu'il en va de la réputation
qu'il s'est un smash surgissent
pour attac il les papilles si c'est pas
plus long que trois mois non non non non
on a dix ans et trois mois lorsqu'un
d'entre elles rouchette ou des scouts
nick ça vous parle oui des avis moi
je passe pas mes journées sur russia
today donc j'ai pas ce
qu elle alors comme d'habitude il faut
voir ce qu'on nous dit non mais je parle
pas je passe pas mis aujourd'hui sur
russia today après je vais pas non plus
jouer le faux pas être non plus à la
posture de occidental qui va dire nous
on a raison avec nos médias et puis les
autres font n'importe quoi je
vais pas je vais pas argumenter en
détail sur russia today par contre je
pense qu'un peu d'humilité pour
tout le monde notamment chez des
occidentaux pour pas coller des procès à
tout le monde en permanence et déjà se
regarder soi même c'est déjà un premier
point après quand roshi atouts des
racontera n'importe quoi il faudrait
c'est pour ça que là on est en france on
n'est pas dans un autre pays mais il
faudrait justement qu'on est j'en sais
rien moi une espèce vous c'est pour eux
non tu pourrait pousser non non non
parce que là pour le coup je pense que
je me sentirai enfin a priori je me
sentirais pas du tout libre de
travailler à russia today voilà c'est
mon point de vue du jour
se sentir libre quand il commençait à
faire bouger ses chaînes oui mais alors
moi je défends par exemple qu'est-ce qui
est déjà libre et à ce qui existe il ya
un an ça vous a pas échappé qu'il ya un
petit soupir tit k o en ce moment sur le
service public qu'on a voulu que la
direction de france télévisions a voulu
dernièrement vidé de son contenu de
rédaction complément d'enquêté envoyée
spéciale en interne en interne à
l'intérieur des murs de france télé pas
en boîte de prod qui elles aussi font du
travail mais là il ya une raide de
rédaction en interne qui font du travail
de fond depuis des années l'idée
au début la au mois de décembre novembre
était de lait digne de diminuer leurs
effectifs de 80 % quand même 1 81% il se
trouve que la résistance qui l'ont
opposé à fait que ce plan était oublié
mais enfin quand même on ya pensé et là
on enlevait d'un seul coup deux choses
d'abord une force de travail directement
intégré dans les tuyaux parce que la
vocation des journalistes c'est pas
forcément dans la sous traitance est
d'être dans son journal pour diffuser en
direct donc on enlevait du pouvoir
journalistique du temps de travail parce
qu' une enquête quand on est protégé par
le service public on a le temps de
l'installer on n'est pas sous mon nez -
sous la coupe budgétaire sous le sous le
sceau choix budgétaires qu'une agence de
presse va avoir puisqu'elle a elle a
hélas x euros pour faire son enquête
point barre au sein du service public on
a un peu plus de temps on enlevait donc
cette capacité là et on enlevait en plus
sur un pouvoir journalistique de
protéger l'ensemble de ce qui est
diffusé sur la chaîne puisque on
enlevait les journalistes ont les
retirait de la 2de la chaîne de télé
donc moi je m'attache déjà à défendre ça
et ensuite vous êtes un bon exemple
évidemment
qu'internet nous offre des possibilités
de créer des nouveaux médias on en est
encore qu'au début et c'est une très
bonne nouvelle et bien entendu qu'on ait
réfléchi à tout ça s'agissant de russia
today j'ai une réflexion qui est qui qui
va pas chercher très loin mais quand on
était petit à l'âge qu'on a
on [raclement de gorge] se on se sont
qualifiés les rues si on se foutait un
peu de leur gueule parce qu'il n'avait
pas de médias qui était
accessible par amour pour nous tu vois
il y avait une espèce de ligne du parti
bah voilà une espèce de ligne du parti
et maintenant qu'il ya des médias russes
qui parviennent jusqu'à nous occidentaux
sans notre propre ligne de parti il
faudrait dire il faudrait dire que il
faut se méfier etc mais enfin c'est pas
parce que on a accès à des journaux
américains depuis condamnés qu'ils
valent mieux ou plus en termes de
qualité de l'information que des
journaux russes qui évidemment ne
peuvent pas être bien antérieure à 1991
pour toutes les raisons qu'on comprend
puis le temps que ça se mette en place
mais enfin on se rappelle quand même que
les états unis d'amérique sont
aujourd'hui gouvernée par trump parce
qu'il a été élu et que les canards
américain relaie les informations des
conneries faites par trump parce que
c'est lui qui gouverne donc l'espèce de
parisianisme qui consiste à dire oui
spoutnik au château des fins moi j'ai lu
des trucs intéressants je sais ni plus
ni moins 6 s'est qualifié en termes
d'information que d'autres
sujets que je peux lire et qui viennent
plus de l'ouest d'où d'ailleurs le fait
qu' il faut traiter tous les médias tous
les médias de la même manière il faut
savoir si oui ou non nous parle
sérieusement si les faits sont vérifiés
c'est en fait il nous manque une culture
populaire de la capacité à vérifier les
infos ouais c'est ça qui manque mais
après c'est vrai qu'on charge la marque
des étudiants ou des collégiens ou des
lycéens avec énormément de choses ils
doivent apprendre à coder ils doivent
apprendre l'anglais ils doivent
apprendre l'allemand devant le chinois
l'arabe et puis en même temps ils
doivent être super bon en maths parce
qu'on a un déficit en maths face et on a
des enfants c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est chaud pour eux c'est compliqué ils
ont beaucoup de choses à apprendre à
voir enfin la guerre de l'information
aujourd'hui nécessite quand même qu'à un
moment donné on puisse avoir un petit
enseignement sûrement les bases pour les
bases vérifier l'info tu jean-loup bien
bah oui nos gouvernements n'ont pas
n'ont jamais intérêt à éduquer les
populations absolument
jamais donc ce que dit jean pierre là
c'est un saint pardon je veux pas être
trop frontal mais c'est un voeu pieux ça
n'arrivera jamais depuis ça n'arrivera
pas c'est de la branlette moi j'y crois
un peu à la bandelette parce que sinon
on n'avance pas 1 on n'a pas besoin
d'espoir pour agir mais il faut agir tu
vois sur l'été sur bfm ça donnerait jean
pierre canet cran la branche [rires]
le banc de bois je sais que ça va faire
un gypse mais je pense qu'il faut enfin
pour la bande à bientôt à la fin
on a encore plein de trucs à traiter la
speed ouais je les faire speed au peuple
le
[soupir]
gars qui a pas content de faire le
boulot qui fait si si si si mais c'est
pas ça ne sais pas si vous avez vous
avez vous enfin récupéré à la maison et
que je veux pas vous lâcher trop tard on
n'a pas des hauts fourneaux monsieur je
sais pas je ne sais pas quelle est cette
révélation par d'autres fait c'est
depuis longtemps ça va ça va vraiment
encore wiki tribunes ça vous parle le
média ça vous parle oui ouais bah
écoute moi j'ai assisté au lancement du
média d'abord parce que j étais invité
et puis ensuite parce que je trouvais
que l'idée d'un média citoyen était une
idée intéressante je dis je trouvais non
pas pour en parler au passé mais pour
revenir au moment où ça s'est produit et
on a entendu assez le média de mélenchon
je connais très très bien les gens qui
s'occupent de ça et ça n'est pas le
média et sont à gauche à gauche quand
même non mais attends si les moins
autant sans cesse que c'est le média de
mélenchon non ça n'est pas le média de
mélenchon ils peuvent être à gauche à
gauche ou à droite à droite et donc je
crois pas qu'ils soient tous de gauche
de gauche pour si les montrent un sens
retirer le sens où mourin joutes de la
mise et écoute
le le sujet là c'est qu'on voit que moi
j'ai su que c'était une bonne idée le
média quand j'ai vu la manière dont ils
sont fait défoncer parce [rires]
que maintenant ma chatte ou des îles
sont fait défoncer donc c'est une bonne
idée mais moi je suis d'accord cela
n'est pas suffisant je dis pas que c'est
suffisant mais je non mais attends tu
leur parles de russia today ou de houe
du média ils sont soumis aux mêmes
droits de l'affreux celle de la presse
que sur
le moment j'ai pas entendu qu'il y avait
des choses tout à fait scandaleuse j'ai
plus entendu parler de déprogrammation
de sujet on a on a un dossier comme ça
en ce moment
ou des intérêts sont un peu bousculé et
où un journaliste on a aura finalement
bosser pour rien pendant un an il se
trouve que c'est également un
journaliste producteur donc c'est pour
sa pomme tu vois pas ce que dans ses
économies il fabrique le sujet sous
celui-ci il va le vendre non non il
pense à attaquer le la chaîne qu'il a
déprogrammé et ils pensent à nous
prendre comme avocat et nous on pense à
leur faire rendre gorge pour pour qu'ils
soient dédommagés voilà comment ça
fonctionne mais on peut se rappeler
avant de crier au loup que tous ces
médias que tu as cité le média en
première ligne est soumis au droit de la
presse et qu'on verra bien s'il merde ou
pas et pour le moment il me semble
qu'ils n'ont pas merdé et j'ai vu leurs
plateaux de lancement un certain nombre
de plateaux depuis jeu je comprends que
dans les dîners en ville ce soit très
chic de ricaner en 10 ans le média de
mélenchon ou le média de la gauche
rachat puis d'abord pourquoi la gauche
n'aurait pas le média ans tu vois je ne
suis pas de gauche donc je m'en fous
c'est pas mon point mais attendons de
voir jugeront sur pièce sans faste ils
sortiront jugeant sur pièce jean sur
pièce ce qui fait sens ainsi si
l'idéologie ou si un pouvoir quel qu'il
soit prend le pas sur l'information bas
ce sera pas bon voilà c'est tout donc
jugeant sur pièce exactement ça jugeront
[soupir]
sur pièce se jugeront sur pièce comment
tu vois l'avenir jean piat au niveau de
ton boulot au niveau 2 tab rejetant que
tant qu'on aura un esprit de résistance
et que je
peux battre surtout n'importe quoi mais
sur les choses importantes tant qu'on
comprendra que on
a des d'abord c'est vrai qu'on aime on
en avait déjà parlé la dernière fois
mais on est dans une destruction
créatrice aujourd'hui je me pète earl
l'économiste qui disait qu'on on avait
des cycles comme ça et c'est vrai
qu'internet ça fait longtemps qu'on le
dit mais rebat les cartes pour le
meilleur comme pour le pire a pas en
france à part mediapart qui est vraiment
le bon exemple on n'a pas encore trouvé
qu est un super bon exemple on n'a pas
encore trouvé forcément
des modèles économiques pérennes qui
permet de faire notamment de
l'investigation ou des sujets même des
reportages à base d'imagés
essentiellement ça coûte plus cher que
les cris qui vivent bien
donc tout ça est en chantier c'est un
magnifique chant de travailler sur
lesquels je pense que beaucoup d'entre
nous vont aller dans les années qui
viennent et puis il ya encore des îlots
il ya encore des choses à protéger donc
je suis préoccupé concentré je crois
qu'on a un bon côté d'internet c'est que
ça a resserré la solidarité du
journaliste voyez quand on quand on sort
les panama peppers il
se passe un truc qui aurait été
impossible il ya 20 ans et que des dites
des dizaines et des centaines de
juristes travaillent ensemble garde le
secret pendant des mois ensemble et
sortent une information majeure mais sa
cdc petit signe d'espoir pour moi c'est
des petits signes d'espoir que
la profession non mais que la profession
a compris qu'il fallait à travailler en
groupe et travailler un peu plus manière
un peu plus solidaire voilà attention
c'est pas une vache et oui oui mais il
ya quand même des signes comme ça qu'ils
montrent que les juristes ont compris
qu'il fallait travailler en groupe a
maintenant il faut des modèles
économiques c'est plus compliqué je vide
ben tu vois j'ai eu la même joie que
celle que vient d'exprimer jean-pierre à
la sortie des panamas peppers parce que
je me suis dit ah ben voilà donc on
allait donner des journalistes ont
travaillé ensemble on voit ce que la
collaboration entre plusieurs fins
fabrique tu vois en termes de
l'information et de révélations de
vérité et puis maintenant il faut aussi
regarder ce qui s'est passé à la suite
de leur scoop mais rien il
ya beaucoup de gens qui nous regardent
maintenant mais rien il ya eu une
commission d enquête parlementaire qui a
fait une espèce de cheat tout à fait
spectaculaire il ya eu des déclarations
de
2,2 de figurants parce que c'est rien
d'autre que des figurants ces gens qui
venaient me dire je me présente à
l'élection présidentielle et je ferais
je ferais je ferais il se trouve qu'ils
n'ont pas été élus comme c'était à peu
près prévu rien d'autre et donc les
banques qui étaient des banques qui
organise et qui fabriquait l'évasion
fiscale n'ont
jamais été sanctionnés donc ces
gens qui sont des journalistes
d'investigation ont travaillé non pas
pour leur gloire parce que j'étais en
contact avec un grand nombre de d'entre
vous tous sur le sujet il pensait
réellement que ça allait changer quelque
chose je le pensais avec le rip
l'intérêt général et oui mais l'intérêt
général ne veut pas ça c'est
triste mais l'intérêt général ne veut
pas ça l'intérêt général veut le
scandale d'après qui chassera le
scandale d'avant que l'intérêt général
commandez de 2,2
de révéler bon ça c'est la grande
question à quoi on sert c'est la grande
question ça
marche pas toujours c'est clair parfois
il ya quand même des raids et il ya
quand même parfois des résultats
concrets je peux en parler des pas de
nom mais bien sûr là dessus bien sûr
mais aussi l'amour et orgue et ou des
choses comme ça où il explique ce même
le clic ça a un peu fait bouger les
choses niveau européen faut quand même
le dire c'est pas c'est très satisfait
par le sort fait à l'aller de luxe mixé
par exemple j'en ai plus que par les
voies plus près ce que ça fait bouger
pour lui dans sa maison dans sa vie à
lui ça la bonne heure donc j'ai grand
chose à susi sa face à faire bouger non
mais ça fait bouger un tout petit peu la
loi de protection des lanceurs en alerte
qui est pas du tout admissibles encore
mais ça bouge un peu de ce côté là au
moins de ce côté là après au niveau
européen c'est pas du tout encore
acceptable et paradis fiscaux existe
bien entendu nous annoncer la fin des
paradis fiscaux et n'importe quoi paris
fiscaux prospère sans problème mais vous
on a quand même il ya quand même je
pense une prise de conscience qui est
plus fortes au sein de l'opinion
publique et il ya des tentatives à un
peu plus forte qu'avant un peu moins
faible de commencer à réguler un petit
peu ça c'est un chantier colossal et je
suis très négatif est très pessimiste
aussi simplement de temps en temps quand
même les enquêtes servent à quelque
chose dans d'autres domaines je prends
un exemple un cachet investigations sur
les pesticides a été refusé à deux ans
qui a notamment parlé du citation des
pesticides dans la région bordelaise
c'est très concret c'est moins sait
moins c'est pas disséminés dans les
circuits des paradis fiscaux bon ça va
changer les pratiques localement donc ça
quand même les choses avancent je crois
qu'elle n'avance pas comme on le
voudrait c'est à dire que ce soit
affichables facilement tuer un seul
convoi l'annoncé le changement non c'est
plus diffus c'est plus lent ça prend
plus de temps mais après nous on n'est
pas là non plus pour tout faire c'est à
dire que nous on sort les infos qui
après la société civile doit s'en
emparer les avocats ce qu'elle veut
c'est les gens qui s'engagent ce qu'elle
fait dans certaines fou parce que les
ong le fond mais
évidemment pas de manière assez
satisfaisante eu d'accord tu
rajoutes et les choses non non
l'intelligence artificielle mes enfants
ça vous fait peur pas peur chez les
avocats ce que l'intelligence
artificielle tu commences à bosser avec
c'est c'est un gros sujet parce qu'on
sent que notre profession est en
mutation et on mène nous au sein du
cabinet 28 octobre une une vraie
réflexion sur les outils dont on doit se
doter parce qu'on a la certitude que le
métier d'avocat qui est qu'elle notre ne
sera plus le même dans quelques années
sans même parler de l'enseigné sur un
plan plus personnel et plus engagés moi
j'ai une une préoccupation qui
tient à la vitesse dont la technologie
évolue et qui n'est pas cette même
vitesse qu'on observe sur les évolutions
démocratiques et il me semble qu'on est
là à l'un des derniers tournants tu vois
par exemple ça elle appelait il ya
quelque chose de juin je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose d'assez incroyable c'est
qu'on te vend ça mais c'est la première
fois qu'un appareil de consommation
courante de reconnaît alors évidemment
il trouve connaît pas toi c'est une
ligne de code mais il
[raclement de gorge] tentant le sait
puisque quand on a syrie et qu'on lui
dont on parle et écoutent ils tentent
enfin oui je vis tu écoutes je sais pas
il tente en ont peu l'actionner comme ça
à la voix et puis désormais il te
reconnais tu vois bien tout ce que ça
d'absolument inquiétant et dans le même
temps moi qui ai un petit sujet
républicain et démocratique parce que
c'est ma fibre mais je crois que c'est
pareil pour toi je me dis il ya des
applis pour n'importe quelle connerie
pour tout et n'importe quoi il ya
toujours pas d'appli pour savoir où en
est la démocratie c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait totalement envisager d'avoir
une application ou au lieu de nous
emmerder en tant que citoyen avec des
sujets comme le mariage gay six mois et
la gpa
encore six mois tu vois on nous dit bon
puisque apparemment il ya un sujet de
démocratie vous voulez vous ne voulez
pas il ya une plate forme il ya une
appli et j'aimerais bien qu'on garde à
l'esprit que en tout cas c'est une
préoccupation que j'ai même et qu'on
garde à l'esprit que si ces évolutions
technologiques vont plus vite que les
évolutions démocratiques alors la
démocratie souffrira de de cet écart et
on voit bien que les autorités publiques
n'ont pas très envie que la technologie
avance à la même mesure que la
démocratie moi j'ai fait une réponse est
un peu enfin quelqu es très générale que
tout le monde utilise aujourd'hui mais
l'intelligence artificielle c'est ce
qu'on va en faire face à pia stieg c'est
assez simple on va qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de l'intelligence artificielle ça
ouvre des champs considérable c'est des
dangers considérables aussi c'est qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de l'intelligence
artificielle dans le domaine du
journalisme ça peut être une aide énorme
il peut y avoir énormément de soutien à
lenquête ou au reportage à travers des
programmes des algorithmes des machines
qui vont aller nous chercher une
quantité invraisemblable de documents
s'est déjà d'ailleurs le cas aujourd'hui
quand on enquête voilà
mais l'intelligence artificielle ça
dépasse largement nos petites personnes
et nous et nous et nos deux aînés nos
deux secteurs d'activité c'est des
questions c'est une question de
civilisation majeur enfin voilà et
là je pense que entre la philosophie la
science fiction les réflexions des
laines musk et autres je pense qu'on a
c'est l'un des grands sujets d'évolution
de l'espèce humaine pour
les pour les 200 ans qui viennent bien
entendu si on n'a pas disparu de par
ailleurs avec le réchauffement
climatique question d'internet quel
avenir pour le slow journalisme un point
d'interrogation en termes économiques
pour interrogation bas on arrête déjà
répondu c'est le journalisme c'est super
prendre du temps pour enquêter c'est
super mais il faut de l'argent parce que
d'abord tout simplement il faut quand
même qu'on vivre de notre métier déjà
avant tout et deuxièmement le travail
journalistique c'est beaucoup de
dépenser beaucoup donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut défendre ce qui existe déjà
notamment le service public à cette
vocation la voilà
avant je vous pose la dernière question
est-ce que vous avez un sujet que vous
voulez qu'on aborde qui vous tient à
coeur un truc qui vous a un petit peu
piqué révolte est apprécié et ont joué
n'importe quoi blanc va aussi en trois
ans à temps plein c'est au moins 3 bat
pas
non mais tout ce qu'on dit là nous
intéresse la serais pas venu tu vois mai
puis on serait pas revenu puisque on ne
serait pas arrivé en avance c'est ça on
te faisant croire que je ne venais pas
ce soir parce que j'étais pris par
ailleurs tu sais que tu risques et
groupe dia ba oui pourquoi tu crois que
les faits sinon c'est pas rigolo moi
[raclement de gorge] ya un sujet qui
m'intéresse de faits divers ont fait
divers et là on est assez servi en
termes de faits divers c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y à un fait divers donc j'en
attends d'aval par exemple où il
est il est fabriqué en termes de la
façon de le raconter si tu veux comme
étant vraiment un fait divers pour
l'éloigner de ce que nous sommes ce que
nous sommes en tant que citoyen
humains en collectivité et donc
l'information
se crispe sur des détails qui font alors
il a menti il était à la table des
parents de la victime la veille quel
[__] on
nous raconte ça comme ça mais
on on ne regarde jamais mon point est un
peu compliquée et compliqué jusque et y
compris dans ma tête en ta communauté
m'excuseras d'essayer de le on ne
regarde jamais ça d'une manière générale
c'est à dire que on peut regarder ce
monsieur jonathan d'aval comme étant un
monstre atroce qui a basculé qui a menti
cas ceci qu'il ya cela et voir ça comme
un fait divers mais on peut revenir
aussi il y a trente ans ou 40 ans je
sais pas quel âge il a dans la classe où
ils étaient dans la tranche d'âge où il
était et se rendre compte que la
statistique de
meurtriers d'assassins de pédophile de
parentis id de ceci de cela et
finalement pour ce qu'on en sait en
droit pénal et en criminologie un peu la
même d'époque en époque donc on voit là
que ça n'est pas traité comme un fait de
société pour le dire autrement tous ceux
qui naîtront parmi tous ceux qui
naîtront aujourd'hui feu rouge bah il y
aura ceux ci cela telle catégorie de de
salopards
qui nous qui nous repousse mais qui nous
révulse pourquoi sans doute parce qu'ils
nous renvoient nous parce que je pense
que ce monsieur je parle de lui et
pardon à son avocat parce que je n'ai
pas que je veux pas rentrer et non de
détails dans nos sections je ne connais
pas mais je pense que ce monsieur a une
vie tout à fait normale sauf les quatre
minutes qui comptent et ce qui va être
jugé ce sont ces quatre minutes alors
que la manière dont la presse le
fabrique mais je veux bien entendre des
contradictions sur la manière dont la
presse se fabrique tu te rappelles les
bébés dans le congélateur encore
hélas non non non non en france ils ont
convenu aussi résister en france oui
mais dans le graphe référence à la faire
voter s'il court toujours
c'est ça alors ça nous était présenté
d'une manière on a tous eu un haut le
coeur est
en réalité qu est ce qui conduit cette
cette femme tu
te rappelles les dénis de grossesse tout
ce truc à se conduire comme ça est
ce que il
n'y aurait pas une manière un peu plus
générale d'aborder cette chose là c'est
à dire ce qui nous tombait dans
l'instantanéité oui je rebondissais
aussi sûr sûr sûr ta question sur la
presse au long cours est sûre qu'est ce
qu'on sait de la [raclement de gorge]
manière dont on dévisse 4 secondes enfin
tu vois cette interview se passe très
bien sauf que s'il se lève et que à la
suite d'une anicroche il te casses une
bouteille sur la tête et tu meurs libyen
il est poursuivi pour meurtre non mais
donc il sera jugé pour ses trois
secondes là pour les deux phrases qui
ont fait qu'il a déclenchée parce que et
là son avocat viendra parler de son état
de fatigue valoir les questions en fait
ce que tu soulèves c'est quoi c'est le
fait qu'on prend pas distance la wii
d'analysé jeu je trouve que la manière
dont ces informations parviennent
jusqu'à nous fabrique systématiquement
des monstres contre lesquelles on a
envie d'être unis en disant tu vois ça
nous est pas arrivé à nous alors c'est
vrai et on va les détaillants détails or
une affaire pénale
un crime de sang c'est toujours des
détails s'il
n'avait pas menti à la famille de la
victime et si tenté qu'il est bien beau
mais c'est une accumulation de choses
qu'on aurait dit tu
vois et là maintenant il ya quelque
chose d'assez nouveau mais j'en avais
déjà fait les frais un peu avant c'est
qu'on commence à regarder il ya le fait
divers dans le fait divers et le fait
divers dans le fait divers c'est son
avocat qui est venu dire ceci cela et
c'est avec sur
les chaînes de hot news où il faut
systématiquement trouver le spécialiste
du machin on vient expliquer où on a vu
des avocats pour quasiment la première
fois mais je redis que j'en avais déjà
fait les frais venir discuter en matière
déontologique du comportement de leurs
confrères et on a vu espèce de ramassis
de connards qui porte la même robe que
moi venir expliquer que la défense qu'a
mis en oeuvre son avocat l'avocat de ce
monsieur d'aval n'allait pas parce que
baby beau but ceci cela c'est absolument
hallucinant qu'on en soit là et ça c'est
fabriqué par les contraintes du hot news
de même que pendant la fête grossman des
camps je suis désolée pour ce que je
veux dire pour certains de tes confrères
dans les noms des avocats au barreau de
paris et de new york alors il était un
spécialiste du droit pénal new yorkais
et on allait l'interrogé sur pourquoi
strauss kahn etc mais faut que les gens
qui te regardent qui nous regardent la
sache que qui les gens qui sont avocat
au barreau de paris aux barreaux de
paris et new york souvent c'est des gens
qui font du droit des sociétés des
fusions acquisitions donc qu'est-ce
qu'il comprenait ces gens-là dossier qui
était un dossier pénal américain et un
certain nombre de médias français
fabriqué des tribunes donnait des
tribunes à ces gens là et là j'ai le
sentiment qu'on voit un peu ça alors il
a pleuré mais pas au bon moment il a
menti mais pas maintenant en train de
dénoncer ou de la due au delà de de
dérives d'une manière d'informer ce qui
a pas une forme tout simplement dit
stérilisation de la société c'est à dire
que oui on peut plus débattre
sereinement et jean-pierre mais qui nous
empêchent de regarder comment quelqu'un
qui a la même qualité que nous c'est à
dire un humain oui à dévisser précis
dans une tranche statistiques si ça
vous fait que dupont moretti avait
rappelé que comme vergès en son temps
quand il défend des des pires criminels
avait rappelé que voilà pour une justice
qui soit digne d'une civilisation d'une
démocratie il faut mettre tout le monde
sur le même plan c'est à dire qu'il faut
juger le fait il faut il faut se calmer
il faut arrêter d'être dans l'hystérie
permanente il faut essayer de s'adresser
il faut déjà considéré que même si il ya
le pire comme le meilleur nous sommes
tous des êtres humains en fait et c'est
simple rétablissement cette information
a rétabli au moment de la ferme et rabat
ça rejoint ce que tu dis c'est à dire
qu'en gros il faut étudier des
trajectoires singulières des vies qui
rejoignent souvent effectivement des
répétitions qui se passe dans la société
qui évolue en fonction de la technologie
des pressions du moment de l'économie de
plein de choses c'est vrai moi je suis
d'accord avec ça qu'on manque de recul
après il ya plein de documentaires qui
prennent le recul mais du coup ou deux
bouquins tu sais que tu les vois trop
tard et humaine mais ça va ça c'est
qu'ils sont pas massif c'est à dire que
pardon
je suis un peu en boucle par exemple sur
cash investigations mais nous on nous
avait dit quand
on a commencé à faire les sujets sur
l'évasion fiscale on nous avait dit mais
vous intéresserait personnes avec ça ça
fait 15 ans qu'on fait des musiciens
dans le dans les couloirs de la télé non
mais vraiment je désigne personne en
particulier c'était nos copains ou quand
on buvait un coup avec nos copains ou
dans notre entourage ou même à la
télévision nous disait voilà il ya peu
de chances que ça marche les uns fiscale
ses emmerdes les gens et c'est donc du
coup qu'est ce qu'on a fait c'est tout à
fait critiquable mais ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a enquêté très sérieusement
et on a utilisé les ficelles de la
société du spectacle pour dire aux gens
aiment bien voir on a un truc à te dire
donc on va faire un sketch de secondes
pour que tu viennes et là on va te
parler d'un truc important et du coup ça
a marché ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que si vous n'utilisez pas des
ficelles liés au divertissement ou liés
à aux pur plaisir du moment
capter l'attention et pour ramener sur
des sujets de fond malheureusement ce
que vient de dire david sur la réflexion
de fond c'est rare que sar enclenche des
réflexions de fonds massives voilà mais
après on n'est pas dans la tête des gens
non plus vous pour ajouter juste un
point sur ce que tu disais ce garçon cet
homme jonathan d'aval qui n'est pas mon
client il va être jugé il va être jugé
après qu'un ministre l'a qualifiée d'
assassin c'est à dire ça ça je te le dis
tout à l'heure c'est un meurtrier qui a
prémédité et depuis quand un ministre
vient position dans une autre question
non c'est un peu la même parce que cette
hystérisation fabrique que n'importe
qui ont dû tous les rôles voilà
n'importe qui tient tous les rôles de la
pièce mais est-ce qu'il serait pas
intéressant pour nous de se poser en
disant bon ok il a tué quelqu'un ses
draps et c'est dramatique et on imagine
la peine des uns et des autres mais
qu'est ce qui l'a conduit à le faire il
ya peut-être une réflexion est ce qu'on
peut empêcher que ça arrive est-ce que
ça se prévient est ce que on peut être
formés à détecter ce genre de choses je
vais poser une question qui va faire
hurler qu'elle est là quel
est le fait générateur tu vois pour ne
pas dire la responsabilité de la victime
parce que c'est pas ça mon poing et
qu'évidemment on ne fait jamais rien qui
mérite qu'on nous assassine ou qu on
nous tue mais qu'elle elle fait
générateur comment l'analyse en humanité
il ya un sujet qui nous intéresse nous
on a juste envie de me garder sur ce mec
en disant que c'est un monstre parce que
ce qu'il a fait monstrueux et alors
après on pourra se délecter de à ce
qu'il a brûlé le corps ou pas et comment
ça a marché mais pendant ce temps on n'a
pas la vraie réflexion et quand la
justice passera parce qu'elle passera eh
bien elle sera gorgé de toutes ces
informations qui
sont des informations en bas tu vois où
tu
as moi je suis me rappelle d'un dossier
précédent ou alors qu'on s'apprêtait à
plaider un dossier
avec une audience qui arrivait six mois
après le président de la république en
exercice avait dit que la personne qu'on
défende et des coupables l'unique
coupable bon bah écoute on part à la
plage alors puisque c'est ça si le
premier magistrat de france se dit que
c'était qui 2
d'abord tu le sais je vais te faire dire
non mais peu importe je ne suis plus en
charge mais la mécanique était choquant
et là je te parle de deux des principes
justement je veux pas être en train
d'illustrer un principe avec un exemple
mais voilà tu me disais qu est-ce qu à
qui tu nous interroger sur ce qui nous
préoccupe sur ce qui nous intéresse bah
un peu de distance et se rappeler que ça
pourrait être nous dans beaucoup de
situations tu vois il ne pas se réjouir
du fait que ce soit l'autre avec cette
espèce de voyeurisme malsain pas mais je
crois pas que les modèles les modèles
économiques des chaînes de d'actu on
continue permet toujours je mangeais un
mot à rajouter c'est qu'en fait ce que
ce qui moi me pose problème et que vous
trouvez moi beaucoup de gens c'est
effectivement cette forme d'hystérie za
sion de la réaction préfère qu on est en
permanence en train de sur réagir à tous
en fait là où on s'insultait jadis ou
bar pmu à 4 m'annoncer sa mondialement
et tout ça est mis sur le même plan que
les informations les plus sérieuses les
déclarations les plus nobles bon oui
mais parce que chaque camp est devenu un
média ouais voilà way jacou oui tout
mais on est tous quoi moi je moi je suis
avec moi je suis reconquis suis devenu
un média je parle là une communauté de
gens sur instagram sur twitter sur
facebook doit aussi lui aussi et c est
donc dès lors qui va te filmer comme ça
en ivoire en faisant des salles fille en
racontant ta journée avec des phrases
qui commence par quand tu sais ces deux
trucs complètement pénible quand tu
rentres chez toi que tu te rends compte
que mais qu'est ce qu'on en a à [__]
en fait rien ou des bars et des phrases
as tu vois à l'indicatif
tu vois ou pire encore à l'infinitif en
disant rentrer chez soi et se rendre
compte de ce que mais pendant ce temps
là tut tut informe pas or on a vu un
certain nombre d'études passe et qui te
montre que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
s'estime
informé une fois qu'ils ont passé une
demi-heure sur les murs des réseaux
sociaux alors
on accélère à telle info on ralentir à
tel autre tu joues tu vois bien le ce
que ça peut avoir deux premiers singles
ces sources oui il faut éviter de côté
source ce la radio la télé journaux
classiques et nouveaux médias lui ont
fait beaucoup les ans je pense pour l
heure rien de remplacer aux médias sans
pub en général c'est je vais faire tirer
les oreilles et maintenant mais une
question d'une clause question on a
assez parlé avez-vous dit oui avez-vous
des soutiens prise de conscience de la
part des juges autre parenthèse sur les
procès bayou où les sanctions
insuffisante les juges sont pas là pour
nous soutenir ou pas nous venir comme le
dit david les anciens juges notent à oui
non mais je crois que trévidic avait
rappaz pas là dessus mais prévenu
qu'elle était intervenue pour défendre
envoyé spécial je pense que là les
compléments de requêtes je pense que ça
avait été très apprécié par les
journalistes parce que voilà c'était
comme une parole un peu d'autorité
trévidic donc c'était sympa mais les
juges sont pas là pour nous défendre ou
pas il faut qu'il fasse vraiment bien la
justice sera déjà bien quelque chose à
rajouter donc
je vais vous poser la fameuse question
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
on va les payer un peu avec un conseil
de lecture et un conseil de philosophes
à lire à écouter à voir donc laissé un
conseil pour les jeunes générations avec
en plus un livre et un philosophe
alliant débrouille
moi
je trouve que pour après j'avais pas 13h
éventuel comment ça il va falloir que tu
reviennes nous voir avec ton associés
parce qu'on n'a pas assez parlé de ton
bouquin et qui on a fait croire la
lisait vincent tout puissant ça c'est un
concert a lieu exactement un livre qui
donc tu mets chez jean claude lattès qui
la fin nicolas vesco hatchi et votre
serviteur va falloir que tu nous y
aurait des bascules moins quand ils
pensent à six mois la fin ça bon c'est
super
et la
facture vient d'en parler comme on a
l'habitude de parler des finances parce
que c'est [gémissement]
mon avis très très intéressant pour le
conseil point jeunes en leur mémoire
après je vais être assez basique il ya
beaucoup de choses à lire évidemment je
trouve que en tout cas pour ce qui vient
nous nous occuper pendant une heure je
trouve que la lecture de giorgio elle
bien au delà de 1984 je pense que je
pense à la aux chroniques à hassaï
please alors français je sais plus
c'était à ma guise voilà les chroniques
amaguiz qui ont été écrites par de
george orwell je crois que ça a commencé
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
ça s'est terminé en 46 de mémoire à
vérifier c'est pas très clair ce que je
raconte mais ces quelques années de
chroniques quasi quotidiennes de george
orwell qui viennent d'être sorte qui
vient de sortir en france qui sont
traduites en français elles sont
formidables parce que george orwell
raconte des choses qui sont extrêmement
moderne est tout à fait lié notamment
aux questions de concentration des
pouvoirs voilà donc moi je trouve un
philosophe et en même temps un écrivain
pas mal non tu m'as fait court 6 parfait
david alors mon conseil aux jeunes
générations bouffer
de la viande on vous fait des ogm ayez
des gros cul regarder la télé ne vous
soulevez pas ça c'est mon conseil
et puis pour la lecture plus
sérieusement donc tout ça est
d'apprendre à l'envers penthouse non
j'aurais dit marc aurèle j'ai découvert
marcorelle quand je empereur beau c'est
sûr
une contestation française que j'ai
publié et j'ai été frappée saisi par la
modernité de la pensée de cet de cet
empereur et notamment des réflexions qui
étaient les siennes et des tu vois les
questionnements qui le taraudait qu'il
habitait sur le sur la manière de
gouverner le livre qui recueille sa
pensée s'appelle j'en sais [__] rien
j'ai lu tout ce que j'ai trouvé il y en
a beaucoup dans le mien d'ailleurs j'ai
repris beaucoup de citations et remercie
pour la dédicace que tu as fait dans ton
coin équipe ça nous a fait beaucoup de
dommages elle fait des choses à rajouter
non non messieurs merci merci à couper
[musique]